so we are all here to discuss living
forever oh we here for a milli second in
time a man gone or is there some
possibility now to transcend that to
achieve something that if it's not
immortal is a very long term of
mortality and indeed are we going to be
the first generation to see that because
some people predict that by 2050 this is
going to be some form of reality
Patricia McCormack she's northa editor
and writer of many academic essays on
dasam Berg he's a futurist transhumanist
and author Yanni is a best-selling
novelist who's known for her adult
novels her essays her short stories so
we are going to kick off and I think
Patricia has nobly volunteered to start
be as immortality does our fear of death
prevent us from fully living yes that's
the end yes but also I'm a deaf advocate
and a death activist and I am Pro deaf
and I would happily like to say the
species died and died out I think we
have destroyed enough other species I
think we had our chance we [ __ ] it up
I think that humans as they exist today
and now are simply repeating the same
anthropocentric destructive patterns and
it's no good and so my big question as a
response would be why are we scared of
death what do we think is so valuable
and precious and important about our own
individuality that it has to keep going
forever
what kind of pathological hubris does
that involve and what would happen if we
decided to decelerate the human
ownership of the earth and start to open
up the world to the possibility of other
organisms we have
seen the cessation of so many species at
our hands why is it that we have such
human exceptionalism for our own species
is it really that valuable because I'm
not seeing a lot of benefit I'm not
seeing you know people many people but
also non-human organisms really jumping
for joy at the idea of humans living
forever and I also think that on a very
sort of intimate level death is the one
thing that we all have in common and it
doesn't matter now
people might disagree with me it doesn't
matter how much money or how much
knowledge you have right now at this
point we're all gonna die and that is
the one thing that reduces us all to the
fact that we are simply material beings
and for many people especially people in
pain or in people who don't want to live
anymore
the ownership of their life is proven to
them as a fallacy because they are made
aware of the fact that under our current
government they don't own their death
and so I think we've got this macro idea
on one side that I am Pro human
extinction and anti-natal astana much
more intimate level on our day to day
living we don't own our deaths and that
shows that we don't own our lives and I
think that in order to really understand
a sense of agency the ownership of death
should be part of the ownership of our
life so and here you have it our life
isn't really particularly valuable and
why should we cherish this in an
egotistical way why would you want to
extend it so I like to kind of agree
with the last part you said I think we
should own our deaths and totally
disagree with the first part otherwise
this would be a rather boring
conversation but we're gonna have some
interesting agreements and disagreement
here so I would start off by saying
right now I feel my life worth living
it's really really enjoyable and you
might argue that actually enters the
reason you feel that it's really
enjoyable it probably some settings of
dopamine neurons in your brain we can
even list some of the genetic variants
and some of the connections causing that
that doesn't change that I'm feeling
really good
and most people I think feel good not
only everybody and not always and that
is something we actually need it to
handle that is also why we should be
able to own our lives and actually try
to make them better and I do think that
on net all living beings want to live
that is unfortunately unfortunately what
we have evolved to do the living being
is that aimed at extinction well they
didn't leave Matt many descendants so
for good Anil we are the kind of stuff
the entire biosphere right now that
tries to keep on going and that leads to
very interesting thing that we are kind
of a smartest part of Iser right now
which I completely admit doesn't mean
they're that smart we don't really know
what we're doing and we're messing up
things in a very bad way in a lot of
ways but we also are aware that we're
messing things up and we can try to
change that so my vision of a future
would be as some of you might have heard
on the space panel that we actually
managed to get our act together get off
this planet to spread life consciousness
in Italian across the universe now if
you're an antenatal is mrs. absolute
horror but it's going to be so many
minds and some of them are going to be
in pain ever it's going to be a lot of
it across viewers at the same time I do
actually think that we should recognize
that in the long run of course the
entropy always wins we right now in this
urn a beautiful spring of a universe
it's long it's just been around for 13
billion years stars are going to be
shining in a trillion years then we're
going to go out but the universe is
going to keep on going for about the
Google years before essentially all
force of history ends when the lost
black hole evaporates you might probably
get life like things going on for at
least ten to thirty six years before
this matter starts decaying I think
there's a potential for an enormous the
great future that has enormous a
positive value and this is partially
because I don't think the pain and the
negative stuff outweighs the positive or
at least we can make sure that that is
positive similarly individually yeah I
do think that viola I like my life it's
not super important doesn't the overall
all our considerations and I'm aware
that even though I want to have life
extension arm signed up for crayons
sooner or later I will end either
because I have an accident
or because I change into something else
again sufficient life extension is
equivalent to becoming something else
even the Christian concept of going to
heaven when you start actually talking
to a field magician about how it is in
heaven you realize that you don't have a
body you don't have any negative
emotions actually an awful of a thing a
lot of the things we normally say make
us ourselves or gone and replaced by
some general be a bright light which
makes it sound like that's actually not
me going to heaven even this is usually
why people don't like talking to fear
logicians about off the life so my
argument would be yes we're mortal even
if we manage to fix our genes and the
backers up in cyberspace so occasionally
things will go wrong and entropy will
always win but I'm not going to kind of
left it in the entropy just we're not
gonna play hide and seek I'm going to
have Robin fun with that we are having a
lovely time Cygnus Hall isn't it
pleasant enough that we'd like to extend
this moment potentially forever I think
if we started going for forever we
probably at some point want it to end
and that's kind of why I tend to agree
more with what Patricia was saying even
though I might not celebrate death quite
as much but I I would like to frame what
I'm saying by first thing we can't judge
life and death unless we look how why we
think we are here and what we're here
for and my perspective on this is that I
think we are guardians of our planet we
are guardians of that little place on
the earth where we are born or live we
don't own it we we should respect it and
actually leave it if we do things right
we should leave it better off than when
we got into the world and there are so
many different ways of doing that that
can be done of course through
environmental protection or so we can
also be done sometimes by your inventing
a great technology for maybe degrading
plastics or writing beautiful poetry or
even just bringing up your kids in a
good way but with that in mind if we are
guardians of this planet then eternal
life is the last thing we should seek
we are what seven going on eight or nine
billion people on this earth and I know
sweetness quite wast and have empty for
you know areas with forests where you
can actually get lost but even in my den
map you can't get lost you if you enter
a forest and you walk for a few hours
you will get out on the other side and
then go to Bangladesh where I work for a
while and I have been pretty shocked
that basically nowhere in the country
except maybe in the northeastern corner
towards Burma will you find any square
meter that is not either inhabited or
arable land just don't find wild nature
anymore I imagine if everyone in
Bangladesh would go for eternal life you
would quickly have those forests and
sweet and populated and then I don't
know if you yourself would anymore enjoy
your eternal life I don't think we want
to have just human beings everywhere
because comes back to a petition say we
already have ruined so many species on
this planet and we're talking about for
the moment that there might not be bees
in a few years and then there won't be
flowers and there will not be very much
life left to enjoy I just like to thank
Yanni and as an Patricia for a really
invigorating tour whose bloody brother
you